foreign
[Music]
19th century suspension bridges were
collapsing all across Europe their
industrial cables frayed during
turbulent weather and snapped under the
weight of their decks
so when a german-american engineer named
John Roebling proposed building the
largest and most expensive suspension
bridge ever conceived over New York's
East River City officials were
understandably skeptical but Manhattan
was increasingly overcrowded and
commuters from Brooklyn clogged the
river in February of 1867 the government
approved roebling's proposal
to avoid the failures of European
bridges Roebling designed a hybrid
Bridge model from suspension bridges he
Incorporated large cables supported by
Central pillars and anchored at each
Bank this design was ideal for
supporting long decks which hung from
smaller vertical cables but roebling's
model also Drew from cable stayed
bridges these shorter structures held up
their decks with diagonal cables that
ran directly to support towers by adding
these additional cables Roebling
improved the Bridge's stability while
also reducing the weight on its anchor
cables
similar designs had been used for some
other Bridges but the scope of
roebling's plan here dwarfed them all
his new Bridge's decks spanned over 480
meters 1.5 times longer than any
previously built suspension bridge since
standard hemp rope would tear under the
deck's 14 680 tons his proposal called
for over 5 600 kilometers of metal wire
to create the Bridge's cables to support
all this weight the towers would need to
stand over 90 meters above sea level
making them the tallest structures in
the Western Hemisphere
Roebling was confident his design would
work but while surveying the site in
1869 an incoming boat crushed his foot
against the dock within a month tetanus
had claimed his life
fortunately John roebling's son
Washington was also a trained engineer
and took over his father's role
the following year construction on the
tower foundations finally began
this first step in construction was also
the most challenging building on the
rocky riverbed involved the use of a
largely untested technology pneumatic
casings workers lowered these airtight
wooden boxes into the river where a
system of pipes pumped pressurized air
in and water out
once established air locks allowed
workers to enter the chamber and
excavate the river bottom they placed
layers of stone on top of the case and
as they dug when it finally hit the
Bedrock they filled it with concrete
becoming the tower's permanent
foundation working conditions in these
casins were dismal and dangerous lit
only by candles and gas lamps the
chambers caught fire several times
forcing them to be evacuated and flooded
even more dangerous was a mysterious
ailment called the bends today we
understand this as decompression
sickness but at the time it appeared to
be an unexplainable pain or dizziness
that killed several workmen in 1872 it
nearly claimed the life of the chief
engineer Washington survived but was
left paralyzed and bedridden yet once
again the roeblings proved indomitable
Washington's wife Emily not only carried
Communications between her husband and
the engineers but soon took over
day-to-day project management
unfortunately the Bridge's troubles were
far from over by 1877 construction was
over budget and behind schedule worse
still it turned out the Bridge's cable
contractor had been selling them faulty
wires
this would have been a fatal flaw if not
for the abundant fail-safes in John
robling's design
after reinforcing the cables with
additional wires they suspended the deck
piece by piece
it took 14 years the modern equivalent
of over 400 million dollars and the
life's work of three different roeblings
but when the Brooklyn Bridge finally
opened on May 24 1883 its Splendor was
undeniable today the Brooklyn Bridge
still stands atop its antique casins
supporting the gothic towers and
intersecting cables that frame a gateway
to New York City
Building Bridges is cool but what about
Subterranean trains how did they dig
massive tunnels under bustling cities
over 150 years ago answer all your
burning questions with this animation on
the origins of the London Underground
[Music]